thanks to dashlane for keeping legal
eagle in the air
have you ever wanted to know how a
lawsuit works most people think of
lawsuits as being these big scary
animals that are completely opaque and
esoteric
but the truth is they are vital to the
functioning of our society and can
right wrongs where they occur but today
i want to demystify the process so that
if you ever need to use a lawsuit or
find yourself in the middle of one
you'll at least know how they operate
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer
today we are covering civil lawsuits or
as most people refer to them just
lawsuits as always be sure to subscribe
and comment in the form of an objection
which i'll either
sustain or overrule i wanted to cover
lawsuits today because there are a lot
of misconceptions about how the civil
process
works and let me start out this
discussion by drawing a distinction
between the civil process of law and the
criminal process the criminal process is
probably the one that you see most often
on tv
and in movies that is where you have
committed a crime
and you are prosecuted by the state and
generally the penalties for a criminal
offense is jail time sometimes there are
monetary penalties that go
along with a crime but the bottom line
is that generally speaking the criminal
process
involves the state prosecuting you for
crimes against
society the civil process on the other
hand is different the civil process is
how you get compensation
for damages that are caused by another
person damages that are caused in the
form of usually
a breach of contract or what we call
torts which are civil wrongs things that
are not crimes
but are violations of norms such that we
believe that one person should
compensate the other generally speaking
the end goal of the civil process
is to receive monetary compensation for
the wrongs that you have suffered
as opposed to the criminal process where
you have done a wrong against society
and you can go to jail as a result
so today we're going to be talking
exclusively about
the civil law process not the criminal
process
and the main tool of the civil process
which is of course the lawsuit now of
course
there are always a million exceptions to
the things i'm going to talk about which
is why there are lawyers and
you should always consult a lawyer
before engaging in any kind of civil
process
but today i want to go over the broad
strokes so you have a general idea of
how a lawsuit works
a lawsuit starts with what's called a
complaint
a complaint is the document that
initiates your civil suit against
somebody else it requires a couple of
things primarily
it is your factual statement of
allegations as to what happened
how you have been wronged and why you
are entitled to some sort of
compensation
it contains a statement of proper
jurisdiction and venue to show that
this particular court is the one that
should be hearing this particular
lawsuit
but for the most part it contains your
factual allegations
your story of what happened and at the
end of the complaint there is a
statement of law that explains the
causes of action that give rise to your
particular claim
so after you have the factual statement
about what happened you'll have the
legal statement about why those
particular facts
fit the elements of a particular cause
of action or claim
and that entitles you to some sort of
compensation
so for example a few weeks back i
covered the fortnite dance controversy
where certain artists were suing video
game manufacturers
claiming that they had stolen their
copyrighted dance
in their complaints they laid out that
these particular artists
had in fact created copyrightable works
in the form of dances
so that was the factual predicate they
laid out that the video game
manufacturers
had taken these copyrighted works used
them without permission
again the factual predicate and then at
the end they stated that this was a
violation of copyright law citing to the
federal standard
for copyright infringement so that's an
example of what the complaint looks like
it's the initiating document it contains
the factual and legal reasoning
for why you think you should get
compensation from another person
the next step after someone files a
complaint generally speaking
is to file what's called an answer or a
motion to dismiss
the person who files the complaint is
called the plaintiff
and generally speaking the person who
responds to the complaint is
the defendant now once the plaintiff
files the complaint
the defendant has basically two options
one is called an answer
the other is called a motion to dismiss
the answer not surprisingly is an
answering document to the complaint
which goes line by line over the factual
allegations in the complaint and either
admits to those particular facts or
denies them now it might seem strange to
admit anything in a
complaint but really in any given
lawsuit there will be things that both
sides agree to
facts that are not really in dispute and
facts that they
deny and that they say never happen so
the purpose of the answer is to
stipulate the facts that are not in
dispute
and to deny the facts that are in
dispute the second option
if it is available is called a motion to
dismiss a motion to dismiss doesn't
challenge the facts of the complaint
there will be time for that later in the
lawsuit the motion to dismiss simply
says that
even if everything that the plaintiff
says is a hundred percent true from a
factual standpoint
it still doesn't give rise to any kind
of legal remedy
it is legally invalid so let's say that
someone files a lawsuit against you for
being a big mean jerk face
well there's no cause of action called
jerkface
the law doesn't allow you to get
compensation
just because someone was a jerk face to
you that might make you a bad person
but that doesn't mean that you have an
obligation to pay them any sort of money
however let's say that someone files a
claim for
defamation defamation requires one a
false
statement of a fact rather than an
opinion publication or communication of
that statement
and fault amounting to at least
negligence and then
suffering damages as a result of that
untrue fact statement
now let's assume that the complaint
alleging defamation
is a hundred percent factually incorrect
you either never said the statement in
question or the statements are true
and therefore it couldn't have been a
false
fact that was communicated in that
circumstance a motion to dismiss
wouldn't work because a motion to
dismiss assumes that the facts in the
complaint
are true a motion to dismiss only tests
the
legal sufficiency of the complaint and
in this particular case
someone has alleged legal predicate for
defamation
there will be time later on to show that
the facts are wrong but effectively at
these early stages
the only things that you can do as the
defendant are either answer or file a
motion to dismiss
which only tests the legal sufficiency
of the complaint not the factual
sufficiency and if you lose a motion to
dismiss
then you will just have to answer just
like any other defendant
so once the complaint and answer have
been filed the court has said that
at least as alleged there is legal
sufficiency for the lawsuit
then what generally happens is you
proceed into what's called discovery
discovery is the process by which both
sides
give up all the information that is
relevant to the particular lawsuit
both the claims that the plaintiff is
making and any defenses that the
defendant has
long gone are the days where you can
ambush people at trial
trial is really just the tip of the
lawsuit iceberg
for the most part most of the lawsuit
consists of this factual discovery back
and forth
because we've decided that it is better
for the judicial process
for people to have all of the relevant
information that is necessary to
adjudicate these cases
before going to trial discovery consists
of
essentially requests from one side to
the other and then responses from that
side back to the original requesting
side
this includes things like
interrogatories which are
questions that the other side has to
answer it
includes document requests where you
request a certain category of documents
and
unless it's objectionable the other side
must respond by providing all of those
documents you'll often see on tv and
movies people talking about being buried
in documents
one way of responding to document
requests is to
not look at them discreetly and
specifically and just giving the other
side
every document that could be responsive
to the request that you have made
so it's often in your best interest to
write your document request in such a
way
that you get the documents that you want
but don't create this really
huge burden from the other side to
compile
hundreds of thousands or millions of
documents as a result of these requests
you
need to thread that needle and of course
discovery also consists of depositions
which is where
you get to question a witness witnesses
are under oath
their responses are recorded by a
stenographer
recently i just reviewed the movie the
social network which is really
interesting from my perspective because
it is told almost entirely
through deposition testimony and you can
imagine that when you're in a lawsuit
being able to question witnesses and
parties to that lawsuit
can be a very very important tool to
find
out what happened in any particular
legal situation
it's a great way to get evidence and to
be able to destroy the other side's
legal claims as well but of course the
downside to
the factual discovery process is that it
is very resource
intensive it takes a ton of time to
draft requests to respond to requests
and then of course to cull through
sometimes millions of pages of documents
just to look for the things that
support your case or support your
defense discovery is what makes up
the vast majority of litigating a
lawsuit so generally speaking once
factual discovery has commenced or has
completed
one or both of the parties will file
what's called a motion for summary
judgment
now where a motion to dismiss
does not attach any evidence whatsoever
because it takes the allegations in the
complaint as
true a motion for summary judgment can
use
evidence you will compile some of the
evidence that you
gathered through document requests
through interrogatories and through
depositions
you will attach that to your motion and
it's basically a
trial on paper the motion for summary
judgment is
a way of ending a lawsuit early without
getting to trial
but the downside is that both sides
effectively must agree
to the evidence that is undisputed and
of course many sides do in fact
dispute the evidence at the motion for
summary judgment stage but a judge will
take that into consideration
and will look at the evidence presented
and actually determine if the parties
really do
dispute the evidence or if the other
side can offer contradictory evidence
so assuming that it's the defendant that
files a motion for summary judgment and
says that even
with undisputed facts the lawsuit fails
the plaintiff can respond
to a motion for summary judgment by
saying legally their case
is still sound and that even with these
undisputed facts they are entitled to a
legal remedy or the plaintiff can
beat a motion for summary judgment by
demonstrating that in fact
the facts go different ways that there's
contradictory evidence
and that the facts are disputed in such
a way that emotion for summer judgment
should not be granted
now assuming that all motions for
summary judgment are denied
that generally leads to pre-trial
motions and what we call motions in
lemonade which are emotions that deal
with
evidentiary issues one thing you see in
legal movies and legal tv shows all the
time
is that they have all of these
evidentiary disputes in the middle of
trial
that's not particularly realistic for
the most part if you
have evidence that a you think is really
really important
and b you think the other side is going
to contest and not stipulate to the
admission of that evidence
what you'll want to do is file a
pre-trial motion to allow that evidence
to come in
so for the most part all of the really
important
evidentiary issues don't happen in the
middle of trial where there's this
perry mason moment where you're not sure
if the judge is going to allow your
evidence to come in or not
that's taken care of months before the
trial
in pre-trial motions and motions in
lemonade because if the evidence is
really important and you need it to come
in
you want to provide as much briefing and
as much legal reasoning as to why it
should come in
or legal reasoning as to why the other
side's evidence should be kept out
because you'll never be able to do as
much uh in oral argument
especially on the day of trial after the
pretrial issues are dealt with that
leads to trial
now less than two percent of all filed
lawsuits ever get anywhere
close to trial for the most part most
lawsuits are either
rejected at the motion stage or they
will settle ahead of time long before
you get to trial because trial is
incredibly expensive but assuming that
you get
to trial of course everybody knows about
opening statements where each side will
explain what facts they intend to bring
out in that particular trial
then you go on to examinations where you
conduct a direct examination of your
witnesses the plaintiff goes first
then each individual witness is
cross-examined by the defense
then the defense witnesses go where the
defendants will
provide their witnesses who are examined
and then cross-examined by
the plaintiffs then there are closing
arguments which is the one place
where you are allowed to engage in
argument
openings are generally supposed to be
argument free just
explaining what kind of facts are going
to come out closing arguments is where
you are
able to tie everything together and then
after closing argument the try or a fact
whether that is a judge or
a jury will render a decision about
which side wins or loses
there can be an appeal on appeal you're
not retrying the facts the facts are
set by the trial court on appeal the
only things that are at issue
are discrete legal issues with a given
set of facts
the court of appeal will look at the
decisions that the trial court made
and determine if they were legally
correct based on those facts of course
there are exceptions to this
but that's generally what's happening
when you appeal and by the way
i have heard so many times people say
i'm going to appeal this all the way to
the supreme court
no no you're not the supreme court
doesn't really review
run-of-the-mill lawsuits the supreme
court only takes a case if there is a
tricky constitutional question or a
question of first impression that deals
with federal laws
uh odds are your lawsuit doesn't come
anywhere close
to those issues so there's no way that
you will ever appeal your case to the
supreme court it's
just not going to happen so that's how a
basic civil lawsuit works use this
newfound knowledge for good
not for evil of course one group of
people that are constantly getting sued
are tech companies because they can't
seem to keep your password secure
dashlane on the other hand protects your
identity across the internet by
providing a tool
that generates strong passwords and
stores and autofills them securely
everywhere on the internet
seamlessly across all of your devices
it's also a vpn which acts as an
intermediary to make sure that all of
your internet traffic is encrypted
even when you're on public wi-fi try
dashlane free for 30 days at the link
below
and legal eagles will get 10 off
dashlane premium
by using the promo code legaleagle at
checkout so click on the link prevent
hacks
and i'll see you in court